[Musique]
vous avez l'air d'un ange
je suis entièrement à votre merci je ne
vous crois pas du tout je peux vous le
prouver le sol sur lequel on marche à
tout moment il peut se dérober on
tombera dans le caniveau mais pourquoi
ça ne pourrait pas changer parce que
c'est le destin
parce que quoi que tu penses toi tu vas
passer ta vie à perdre mais ne croyez
vous pas qu'il soit possible que la
gentillesse et l'amour puisse changer un
homme qu'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant votre petite chérie ne
manquera de rien tant qu'elle sera avait
été la renier
une enfant devrait pouvoir jouer de
temps en temps surtout à noël j'en
connais qui ferait bien de s'occuper de
leurs affaires
tu ne connais pas le monde causette
mais je veux découvrir par moi même
paris est un fagot de bois sec
une étincelle il mettra le fun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]